[Musica]
salve per me è un piacere parlare con
voi oggi dello strumento che unisce di
più
nell'incanto e nella mera azione l'arte
in ogni sua forma
in particolare vorrei condividere con
voi alcune riflessioni su uno dei
maggiori capolavori dell'arte pittorica
italiana la deposizione di caravaggio
io però non sono qui per darvi una
lettura di quest'opera né tantomeno per
darvene una sua descrizione non vi dirò
infatti che è stata dipinta tra il 1600
2 e il 1604 o che si conserva presso la
pinacoteca vaticana neanche vi dirò che
si compone di sei personaggi i quali
rispecchiano il realismo e l'uso della
prospettiva che rivoluzionano la pittura
italiana
al contrario mi piacerebbe che vi
concentrasse su ciò che rende unico ogni
capolavoro artistico su ciò che è
l'essenza stessa dell'artista ma so ciò
che purtroppo spesso la maggior parte di
noi non sa cogliere il dettaglio e
caravaggio è peculiare in merito al
dettaglio perché è lui che dà
significato e costruzione ad ogni sua
opera ed è lui che ogni volta veicola il
messaggio che egli intende mandare
guardate assieme a me la tela dietro di
voi e osservate il braccio di gesù e
mettetelo in relazione con il suo corpo
potrete vedere che mentre il corpo di
gesù e privo di vita in apparente
contraddizione le vene del braccio sono
in tensione
questo per citare il ruolo del cristo
che è quello di redimere l'umanità dal
peccato e dalla morte attraverso il
proprio sangue che li dona
volontariamente ad ogni essere umano
adesso guardate il dito di gesù che
indica la lapis funzioni il latino la
pietra dell'unzione il cui angolo buca
per così dire lo schermo in questo caso
questo a citare il salmo secondo il
quale la pietra scartata dal costruttore
sarebbe diventata la testa dell'angolo
guardate ora in basso a sinistra dove
troverete una pianta con le foglie
rigogliose che si chiama tasso barbasso
over basco che come tutti sanno era
usata per fare gli stoppini delle
candele quello che però non è sempre
noto è che questo piccolo arbusto
rappresenta la vita quindi a me in
questo contesto particolare mi piace
accostarlo alla resurrezione del cristo
tanto che la sua vitalità contrasta con
la secchezza della pianticella che
invece si trova in basso a destra che
quindi potrebbe essere collegata alla
morte il sacrificio di gesù il cui peso
è sostenuto da nicodemo di cui vedete al
centro della dello schermo alle spalle e
la schiena piegati e quindi la chiave
che libera l'umanità dal peccato e dalla
morte prima che egli sia risorto
ma perché io ho voluto condividere con
voi questi dettagli tanto piccoli da non
poter essere colti senza un esame
attento
la ragione è duplice
la prima è che il dettaglio permette la
piena comprensione del messaggio di
qualunque natura esso sia è la seconda è
che il dettaglio permette di cambiare la
prospettiva delle circostanze che man
mano ci si presentano e quindi le
decisioni e di conseguenza le nostre
azioni per farvi comprendere meglio però
vorrei parlare con voi dei colori voi
conoscete che esistono i colori primari
eco principali che ci trasmettono
un'idea di completezza totalità o
pienezza
secondo me però la loro vera forza la
loro pregnanza sta nel fatto che se ben
abbinati o combinati e si creano un
numero infinito di sfumature
i colori sono sempre gli stessi ma le
sfumature che si creano sono infinite
allo stesso modo la vita come affermava
il filosofo latino seneca è per tutti
uno spazio di tempo limitato ma sono gli
episodi di cui è costellata che la
rendono
unica e degna di essere vissuta se noi
quindi troviamo il coraggio di cambiare
la prospettiva delle nostre circostanze
siamo anche conferiti dell'unicità e
della dignità del privilegio di vivere
privilegio che molto spesso purtroppo
non cogliamo a me è accaduto proprio
questo l'arte rappresenta la metafora
della vita che io ha volontariamente
deciso di condurre un'esistenza fatta di
dettagli e di conseguenza di azioni
mosse da uno sguardo che di volta in
volta si è ampliato mai fermandosi alla
superficie
io dopo il liceo classico ho deciso di
continuare gli studi umanistici
intraprendendo la facoltà di lettere
classiche con piena gratificazione sì ma
certo non senza difficoltà
ogni volta che superava un esame che
uscivo da quella stanza infatti provavo
la sensazione entusiasmante ed
avvolgente di chi fa quello per cui è
nato e questi traguardi
man mano che l'ipo inseguivo pur senza
sapere se in effetti ci sarei riuscita
stavano dipingendo il quadro della mia
vita ma soltanto con i colori di base le
sfumature per me si sono delineate o
almeno hanno cominciato a delinearsi nel
2010 quando in uno dei musei più
prestigiosi del mondo
ho incontrato il mio mentore una donna
fantastica che tra 50 persone li
intervenute per una visita ordinaria
accolto proprio il mio sorriso
questa persona mi ha insegnato ciò in
cui non avrei mai sperato ma che avevo
sempre desiderato e cioè a vedere l'arte
esa significati nascosti
grazie al suo insegnamento non solo ho
potuto guardare ogni dettaglio espresso
dall artista ma soprattutto ho
intrapreso il mio viaggio verso la
persona che voglio diventare verso
quella persona che il dolore per troppo
tempo mi aveva tolto all'interno del
percorso che ho fatto con lei ho potuto
con anche l'ausilio degli altri sensi
guardare letteralmente ogni opera d'arte
infatti ho potuto toccare le stoffe
narrate nella scena ho potuto ascoltare
le musiche suggerite dal contesto o
annusarne gli odori queste sensazioni mi
riportano spesso indietro alla mia
infanzia quando come tutte le bambine
giocavo con le bambole e altrettanto
classico perdevo la scarpetta di barbie
così andavo dalla mia mamma gli chiedevo
di aiutarmi a trovarla ma lei mi
rispondeva sempre con una frase mi
diceva trova da sola usa quello che hai
e io effettivamente non capivo ma
piangevo e le tornavo a chiedere aiuto
ma lei era irremovibile
fino a che il risultato fu che io in
effetti trovai la scarpetta e gliela
mostrare felice crescendo però le chiesi
perché ne avesse trattato così perché
fosse stata così cattiva con me e lei mi
rispondeva che nonostante se n'era
prestasse in realtà era necessario alla
mia autonomia alla mia risolutezza e
alla mia responsabilità io ancora adesso
onestamente mi chiedo come mia mamma
abbia potuto comprendere talmente
profondamente sua figlia me da poter
intuire addirittura prima di me quali
fossero le mie inclinazioni le mie
attitudini ma soprattutto la mia volontà
forte del suo supporto potei quindi
scegliere di andare dietro alle mie
passioni
anche quando esse erano insolite oppure
sconsigliate consapevole della sua
fiducia e della sua lungimiranza poteri
assecondare so che mi dettava il mio
cuore l'amore per la vita e l'amore per
il sapere e questo è stato determinante
per poter soddisfare la mia curiosità di
provare ogni esperienza e di conoscere
ogni emozione da quella più forte a
quella più comune a tutti i risultati di
questa curiosità sono stati molteplici
ad esempio le tele che io stesso ho
realizzato guidata dalla sapiente mano
delle mie insegnanti creando anche delle
sfumature
oppure i dipinti su stoffa in questi
anni ho appreso una verità fondamentale
le uniche persone che si pongono dei
limiti siamo noi stessi e siamo sempre
noi stessi che definiamo impossibili le
strade che ci rifiutiamo di
intraprendere come succede quando si
decide di cambiare il corso delle
proprie circostanze ho cominciato ad
essere circondata di persone che come me
condividono la stessa mission di sfidare
il limite là dove è impossibile
tutte queste persone hanno contribuito a
farmi alzare dalla sedia e a cambiare di
nuovo la prospettiva ancora attraverso
un dettaglio
ognuno di loro non ha accettato l'idea
di arrendersi
ognuno di loro si è mosso ed è così non
stando fermo che ha fatto le vere
scoperte
una di queste scoperte è una tecnologia
sviluppata da chi crede che si possa
provare ogni esperienza da parte di
tutti anche da parte di quelle persone a
cui prima essa era preclusa il genio e
l'illuminazione di queste persone ha
permesso di fruire in autonomia
dell'arte anche ad individui che come
principale risorsa possiedono tatto e
udito ma che fino ad ora hanno creduto
che il bello dell'arte non fosse per
loro come non lo sarebbe stato per me
che ho un particolare problema che
tecnicamente mi fa definire non vedente
io ma non vedente lavorando con questi
strumenti e osservando la gioia di chi
in autonomia indipendenza ammira
un'opera d'arte
ho imparato un'altra cosa che l'artista
quando crea un suo capolavoro lo fa
assemblando una serie di dettagli per
rappresentare il proprio genio
emozionale la propria creatività la
propria ispirazione per farla vedere non
ha una categoria di persone specifica
bensì a tutti
tutti infatti devono poter ammirare ed
apprezzare un'opera d'arte senza
proibizioni le imposizioni e caravaggio
quando ha dipinto la deposizione ha
scelto di soddisfare il proprio estro
rappresentando i suoi personaggi nel
proprio dolore e nella
propria povertà questo lavoro oggi è
ricordato che apprezzato a dispetto di
chi invece all'epoca lo aveva giudicato
e disprezzato come caravaggio ha fatto
in pittura anche io nella mia vita ho
deciso categoricamente di ignorare chi
mi ha sempre detto questo non lo puoi
fare
e a questo severo divieto ho deciso di
rispondere compiendo esattamente le
azioni che quelle persone mi avevano
detto di non fare soltanto in questo
modo ho potuto sentire cose che gli
altri non sentono ma soprattutto vedere
cose che gli altri non vedono quello che
ho imparato è che vorrei condividere con
voi è che la curiosità l'amore per il
dettaglio e la forza per cogliere il
senso di questo dettaglio mi hanno
permesso di imparare a vedere l'arte con
la a maiuscola
in realtà oggi per me questi tre
pilastri sono molto di più sono le
costanti di una formula che mi ha
insegnato a vedere l'arte ma che mi ha
insegnato molto di più a vedere la vita
grazie
volevo condividere con voi un ultima
cosa per cui ringrazio sentitamente
tutti coloro che si sono impegnati
perché questo è uno degli strumenti e
forte in questo caso è lo strumento che
mi ha permesso di raccontarvi la
deposizione di caravaggio e di farvela
vedere come la vedete voi ma attraverso
i miei occhi
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]